the greatness with which he played right
field yeah absolutely uh the idea i
think of a lot of the throws or what we
see when we
see some of these highlights over
roberto clemente obviously a great
athlete ran really well
that's what he's most remembered for
interaction with fans and people for
kyle cody it's a slider 14 fastball he's
got the two seamer and the change up as
well he's been very impressive so far
there's the first one it's chopped on
the ground on the right side of door far
to his left throws to first and safe at
first base if you'll face it anthony
rendon with a runner in scoring position
nonetheless next pitch this is a shot up
the middle that's going to fall in for a
base hit simmons will be waved home
there will be no throw to the plate and
that'll be an rbi single with two outs
by rendon and the angels have a
one-nothing lead
this is pulled to the right side and
beyond the reach of odor to right field
turning and heading to third bases
rindome
barrel ends up behind the first base
coaches box and shohei broke his bat and
the angels have runners at the corners
with two outs albert is this one on the
ground the third base kind of for luffa
across the diamond
guzman has to dig it out unfortunately
he does otherwise it costs the rangers a
run angels take the early lead as we
head to the bottom of the first julio
tehran who's making the start tonight
for the angels it's been a struggle so
far
he bounces this one left side of the
infield and it's
glanced out
into left and so isaiah will extend the
streak to 12 games this was kind of a
last-minute initiative for major league
baseball and john blake explained today
that there just wasn't enough time to
have enough uniforms for everybody to
wear 21 and so after they went to any
natives of puerto rico and then it was
veterans say that you have puerto rican
heritage and you're bringing your kids
to the game and there's three players
that are wearing 21. well that's a cool
conversation you get to have with your
kids and i think an extra sense of pride
knowing not only was roberto clemente a
very special player and a very special
human being but here are players also of
puerto rican heritage that are wearing
his number right now on the field i
think it could work both ways whatever
size ultimately we will see 3-1
bounces up to the plate so they're
loaded three straight walks
and that is
not a great sign and here comes the
skipper and he chases strike three
and strikeout the second out of the
inning and a big one for jesse chavez
down the right side into the corner
forward gallow and he'll make the play
the inning is done so chavez
takes over a bases loaded spot and he
leaves all of them out there
and it's still one nothing
one-two
bamboo this one out the left-field side
area and that is gonna fall in there for
a base hit why cuts it off bamboo
with a one-out single
taking off on the ball was
then
and that is off the glove of guzman gets
away and because ronifa was on the move
he's going to come around to score from
first base and got a break on that one
talk about having runners in motion
force in the issue pick up a run out of
it
two nothing halos
[Applause]
late swing and that one poke pass first
and kinder felefa is going to turn and
go for two and the throw won't get him
so isaiah with some aggressive base
running
stretches that into a double that's a
good start to the fourth inning nick
solak could drive him in with a base hit
here oh that ball smoked up the middle
base hit for solac that'll get isiah
counter philippa home
so the rangers get on the board and it's
a 2-1 ball game thanks to solac that
ball
was sizzled
tehran
gets him to hit this one
in the air
looks like it's heading foul ground
right tight another left side no that
drops in base hit and taheda was
hustling all the way and he's safe in
its second with a double
wow
i was watching rendon and it looked like
he was peeling off for a foul ball when
in fact i think he was just
peeling off for this all right well now
eli white once again
with that opportunity
that ball hit hard into the left field
corner base hit for eli white and it
will tie the ball game and there's his
first big league hit and like i said you
get that first one and perhaps
we will see
many more for eli white he is in the
books
and not only that he's nodded the game
with that rbi double
2-2
and that one flared out towards center
trout coming on quickly can't get to it
drops in for a hit
and so the rangers have them loaded
tough play for
the runners white and tavares
here he comes
and that ball in the air on the center
field will be deep enough to get a run
home
trump makes the catch
white tags and scores and it's 3-2
rangers have the lead
two balls two strikes two outs two on
the pitch is swung on and grounded
through the vacated left side a base hit
tavares rounding third and he will score
joey gala with an opposite field single
makes it 4-2 texas
at 10.
and an 11 pitch
walk brings home a run
5-2 rangers and that's a great at bat
for o'dore
oh
did that get guzman
on a 3-2 pitch he's hit by a pitch
it'll bring home a run he's not happy
about it it's 6-2
rangers the inning will continue and
but that one just kept kind of riding up
and in on him
this ball ripped into right field
hard that's a base hit for tavares
and he'll have two and he'll stop there
nice footwork
we thought about it
we're going throw down to second not in
time headed to the plate safe there as
well a double steal of home and the
rangers add to the lead
wow
perfectly executed by the texas rangers
nice over two of the walk that is ripped
out to right field hit well this one is
gone a big fly for matt feis
sneaks it over the right field wall his
first of the season at seven of three
texas first rbi first extra bait
simmons at second base and the payoff
pitch
in the air
center field
tavares measures it
and the rangers have taken two straight
to start this series from the angels 7-3
our final score